i'm bryce dallas howard and i am the  voice of bella in the new movie a dogs  way home this is the story of the  extraordinary lengths a dog will go to  in order to get back to their family of  course the dog the play bella would have  to be a rescue we discovered she'll be  at a shelter in tennessee where she had  been living in a junkyard immediately  you could tell that shelby was gonna  take us on an amazing journey she's  incredibly spirited affectionate and  bright we found our bella and she had no  idea how much her life was going to  change since filming she's become a  therapy dog and knows this is her new  profess'd to take care of people and to  make them feel loved  join me and she'll be on our adventure  in a dog's way home in theaters January  11  [Laughter]  [Music]